ازهار اكبر متوقع لسوق المنتجات الفاخره
مستعمله خلال 20 23 وسط ركودا وشيك ينتظره
العالم سوق السلال فريحه المستعمله ليس
شيئا مستحدثا لكنه يبدو انه سيعيش ازهى
اوقاته في العام الجاري مستفيدا من
التراجع الاقتصادي العالمي
اخره الذين لم يتحمل ارتفاع تكلفه عن
منتجات مستخدمه للابقاء على هدامهم بتكلفه
اقل العلامات الفاخره تواجه معضله ما بين
دخول السوق المستعمل الذي يضر ذهبا لزياده
ارباحها او تجاهله تماما حتى لا تفقد
حصريتها امام عملائها بالغين فرع اللذين
لن يتاثروا على الاغلب بارتفاع الاسعار
والاجانب اخر من القصه سوق الساعات
الفاخره المستعمله سيتفوق على الساعات
الجديده في غضون عقد من الزمان
هذا السوق الى 85 مليار دولار في عام
2033 وهو اكثر بثلاثه اضعاف ما تم بيعه
خلال العام الماضي روليكس ولاول مره قرر
الدخول ميدان بيع السلعه المستعمله حيث
اطلقت برنامج معتمدا لبيع الساعات
المملوكه مسبقا في ست دول اوروبيه
جاءت في ديسمبر الماضي بعد ما انخفضت
اسعار الساعات بشكل حاد بسبب زياده العرض
مع استمرار انخفاض الطلاق الشركه
السويسريه تريد السيطره على السوق وتقول
انها تريد عبر هذه الخطوه ضمانه اصاله
الساعات بيعها من قبل بائعين رسميا لكن
رولكس تواجهم منافسه مع تجار ساعاتها
المستعمله الذين قد يصطارون الى خف
باسعارهم للمنافسه والمزاحمه على
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
العالم
الجديد استعمال
مثل ما شفنا حيضاع في ثلاث مرات ال 85
مليار دولار مثلا رولكس طب ما انا استفيد
ليش تيجي سرت بارتي يجي وياخذ هذه الفلوس
اللي بدها تصير المبيعات مش الكل قادر على
دفع طبعا اللي يقدر يشتري وحده جديده
هيشتري جديده بس بنفس الوقت هناك ايضا
مجموعه ثانيه اللي يريد تشتري الاشياء
اللي تنتج القديمه اللي اصبحت نادره اليوم
هذا اللي تلعب عليه رولكس ايضا واحده هم
وفاتك فيليب يلعبون على الساعات اللي صارت
نادره اليوم وايضا مثل ما قلنا هي مساله
ايدينتي
كمان هو جيل جديد يعني جيل عملي اكثر صحيح
طب اليوم اذا شخص بده يروح على محل يشتري
هذه البضاعه وهذه السلع الفاخره المستعمله
يعني كيف بدنا انها مش تقليد مثلا هي هاي
المشكله
لعبتها صح لما هي دخلت على السوق نفسها
مثل وترماس مثل ما تساويش عنال لانه همم
التقليل جدا صعب وفاري هارد انه تميزي هاي
بنايه حتى الشهادات اليوم يقلدوا لك اياها
اللي اكبر الشركات يقلدوها في الصين وتباع
بس هناك بعض التبس المعينه اللي بننظر
الها اول شيء عندك اللي مثلا المعدن مثلا
لنفترض في شنطه حقيبه كل او اكثر شيء يبين
المعدن الزبر السحابه الخياطه لازم تكون
جدا دقيقه المقلده بعدين في كلش حلوه اللي
هو انه المقلد هو يقلد على الصوره ما عنده
الحقيقيه اغلب الاحيان جيوب اللي يحطها من
الداخل الداخل دائما مختلف فانت روحي
واختي نظره
صحيح فانت دائما روحي اخذي النظره على هذه
الحقيقه قبل ما تشتريه وشوفي الجيب وين
شوفي التفاصيل الداخليه مثلا على همم على
الحقائب والملابس والاستكز هذه من الامور
بس ما زال هناك العديد من النصب والاحتيال
وميميزوها خصوصا في سوق الثانويه
من احد المولات التجاريه بجده سان
المتسوقين هل يمكن ان تشتري منتجات فاخره
مستعمله
هلا ممكن تشتري حاجه فاخره بس مستعمله
وليش طبعا اكيد وخاصه عشان قيمتها
المعنويه اكثر من سعرها خاصه اذا كانت
مقتناه من همم يعني قبل من شخص مثلا
الامام معنويه كبيره او شخص مهم
فيها جوده عاليه وتكون مثلا مثلا قويه كده
وفيها حاجه مضبوطه
[موسيقى]
ممكن اشتري حاجه فاخره ومستعمله اذا فيها
جوده فيها حاجه كويسه كده واعجبتني انا
ممكن اشتريها
زي اللوحه
فاخره حلوه عرفت اسم الفنان حتى لو ما
ببيعها رخيص
طبعا
ممكن اشتري البس حاجه من بعد ما استخدمه
طيب سمر شاهدنا يعني ارتفاع كبير في نمو
سوق الحقائب والجلد خصوصا جهه العالم
الفاخره المستعمله حديثنا اكثر عن سبب
النمو وهنتوقع نمو اكبر بالنسبه للحقائب
الفاخره غير انه مساله مثل ما نرجع قلنا
اليوم في ترند ايضا نستله السوريه او
اعاده استعماله واعاده رسايكل يعني اعاده
استخدام هو ترندي يعني طاش بين
السلبرتزوه الاجيال الاخرى ايضا هناك شغله
مهمه انه اتغيرت الجنود اللي يستخدموها
اليوم عن اللي كانوا يستخدموها سابقا يقول
لك انه الجلود اللي كانت سابقه هي هوايه
احسن ونوعيتها افضل من الجلود اللي
استخدمها اليوم وذلك بسبب هناك العديد من
القيود على عمليه التصنيع بسبب تلوث
البيئه وغيرها وطبعا بالتاكيد مثل ما شفنا
بالتقرير انه بعض الناس تنظر الى الشيء هو
اليوم هذا الشيء الموضه انه يجيب الاشياء
اللي بينتج القديمه
وترجعيها مره اخرى وهو طبعا من اكبر الاس
اللي يصير فيها اعاده بيع هي همم الحقائق
الفاخر يعني طيب يعني بتحسي راح ينتعش هذا
السوق ويزداد نمو اكثر فاكثر يعني زي ما
واضح انه لاحظنا الناس يعني مش المعارضه
فكره انه تشتري مثلا شنطه مستعمله صح
الارقام تقول انه حيصير نمو 10% سنويا
خلال سنوات ال همم القادمه وهيوصل فوق ال
50 مليار دولار خلال ثلاث سنوات هذا همم
تقريبا اكثر من 50% هيكون من نصيب حقائب
الفاخره بس في شغله كمان خطره تعبانه لانه
هل احنا كاشخاص علينا ان نستمر
بالحقائب مثلا والساعات لكي تكون مشروع
استثمار في المستقبل ابيعها في اي وقت هلا
ما اريد نسوي دعايه بس هو اذا تستثمرين
لتستمرين
يعني اللي طالع موده
الكلاسيك اللي حقيبه مو مو البوي الثانيه
نسيت شو اسمها الورديه اكتبي البنتج
القديمه اغلى من الجديده اوكي عرفتي يعني
صارت اخذه مع انه هي تقريبا نفس اللون
ونفس الكات وكل شيء بس لانه على اساس هاي
بنتج او مملوكه وفيها ستوري تعرفون اليوم
مع السوشل ميديا الكل يدور على ستوري كل
شيء لازم الى ستوري فهاي المره اللي كانت
شاريتها كانت مسافره بفلان مكان وتسوي كذا
دائما